[Laughter]
first of all how are you all thank you
so much for tuning again a 5 p.m.
yeah today's objective together it's
done in 10 minutes
but first before we start that amazing
we did it is a household staple I just
want to stay a very special thank you
yet again to captain Tom Moore
I mean extraordin what a week he's about
to surprise 30 million pounds rates for
the NHS we know how hard those amazing
women and men are working 24 hours
around the clock not only is this guy on
the budget range in 30 million pounds
but he's a hundred years old
next Thursday we have to make this the
biggest celebration can we do a national
happy birthday to that amazing captain
can we do it at five to eight before the
invasion is clap I don't know but let's
get together and get the nation singing
one big hell of a happy birthday to an
extraordinary man and he's gone and got
the number one spot as well I mean
honestly son account missed that one
didn't he big time
what an amazing an amazing performance
and a big thank you to Mike more little
lives in : NHS and right the girls are
back in town
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
got some milk we've got some biscuits
custard creams some cornflakes for
breakfast baked beans on toast
Oscar awesome is it daddy right here we
go right hand down let's go
oh yeah okay right mr. chips in turn
don't stop the clock yeah let's go right
ingredients cut okay
now I got this one for sure rock rock
rock fish thank you there's a just
outside the promenade of layin nice wait
hurry up don't cook cause I've got one
egg whites hundred and twenty grams of
subway in class something that gives the
actual a monk is the lightness and the
Christmas that amazing better a little
bit of baking power come on grandma
everyone's got baking powder in there
okay
I don't like any part that lifts the
batter makes it a bit more spicy fifty
tips that's mine and then some video of
course liberal beer and the batter is
going to be flamed by this beer again
give it aeration from the hops and the
yeast and gives it a really nice touch
okay and just one potato a care of them
for large large waxy potatoes peeled and
I'm gonna go a little bit dry because
I'll get these things crispy will not
find these potatoes in ten minutes we're
not going to spend 15
it's one of five them three times
they're going to take about three
minutes to make the most amazing potato
depending on the time depends on the
thickness you ladies ready dad if only
you could cook is called as fast as you
speak Calvin I'm so sorry
hey first of all you're choosing unlike
beetroot good news is you're out in time
you know for another three years if I
got banned from Vegas Mercator let's get
this thing a little bit more flavor some
teaspoon of baking so it's a teaspoon
they'll aerate it up after that I want
to flavor it start the clock please hold
thank you a little bit of curry powder
and I've put a little bit of curry
powder in the seasonal plan as well just
gonna dredge yeah actual beautiful Cod
in there now fear it's about 160 ml so
just be under half a bottle okay
I'll sift the flour now give it a really
good mix right now get you all on
come over here pan down back I've got a
frying pan was worried about fryers stop
the fryer just a Tesco special non-stick
pan 11 pound 99 and cause the Box the
cornflakes get the heat hog and work it
up okay just a basic pan I'm shallow
frying okay
I'm not deep frying big difference Thank
You Oscar literally agrees with it
shallow firing the way therefore we take
on less fat and more importantly the
actual flavor is delicious
now we're studying okay you want it
almost sort of like a runny texture
touch more beer okay you can make this
batter without the beer okay now from
there once you've got that a nice sort
of liquid moving like that okay whisk
you finger sleep i season it lightly
okay with that texture pan down big pan
down Meg
20 gin and tonics last night girl poured
into sin no no
right now from there literally bang the
whisk gear egg whites okay
and whisk those egg whites now whisk
them three quarters okay
just if peak okay that means basically
Tilly stop it laughing the sticking away
to just open there don't put the top too
early
okay now once you've got that aeration
those egg whites okay look from there
straight into the batter pen down make
pen down there you go excuse me look
white hand every piece for Miriam now
look at two days gone thank you look at
that butter beautiful you want the
batter just dropping through the risk if
he gets a little bit too heavy a special
water in there look at the color in that
curry powder gives that a really nice
beautiful dark color now we have to
dredge this let's get the fish in first
I'm gonna season the fish first before
we go into the flour
cuz you can't see the fish once it comes
out cuz that batter stills it in okay
now lightly seasoned into the flour run
it through those spices and then this is
really important now okay knock off that
flour so just feel next the right don't
jump it okay now look from there take
the fish and just literally drop that in
yes okay don't get that oil too hot if
it was too hot okay
just thank you all sunflower oil and
just put a tablespoon I'll call them
there okay that's why I've started with
shallow fry so there's so much more
control over there yeah watch lift it up
and then literally from side to side use
the corner of the cod and this is so
beautiful so fresh lay away from you put
it in okay I'm just literally lay away
now I've got to take it off the gas
there's no need more heat quick wash
their hands okay now like I said if
you're probably gets too hot okay add a
splash of cold on to it
but look at that now look shallow fry
turn the gas down and stick that back on
there take a little spoon and just put
the back of the spoon just face the fish
and literally this is the exciting part
about basting fish this special or a
prime is shallow fry they get really
nice and crispy now look at the color
that back to pan down make how we do
time hold please four minutes gone right
potatoes just very quickly square that
off means top and bottom okay and
literally square it off so it's all nice
and flat so is easy to cut and they come
down here now we haven't got long
so these gonna be tall skinny fries from
there in
and then from there look down hold them
all together uniformed
this is one potato but look at the yield
of fries on there okay and then finally
there now get them into a little piece
of kitchen roll okay and Rob them okay
when you rub them it gets rid of the
start and the moisture okay and it helps
to dry the potato batter now lift up to
the side turn that over and then this be
faced again now
cello prime should take literally around
three to three-and-a-half minutes now
look at that beautiful color again
clothing size and then its face now once
you've got to color on there okay the
fish that thing cooks in about three and
a half minutes
that's a nice and crispy and from there
I'm going to take it out literally drain
it aside put that onto a little piece of
the paper okay and that gets rid of the
excess fat and litter that's been go in
the oven for about two minutes
now the fries quack up the gas literally
a touch of cold water in there because
with a blank sheet potatoes first I've
rubbed them nice and dry and look we're
gonna go in into the same oil now you
can see the difference now see how thin
they are and he's gonna cut loose we -
it's time please hold for Miss don't
worry don't worry now they're in there
we blanch them now pillow makers needs
me sign up now to change the bludgeon
could be always cold but a writer okay
the gas is nice and hearts are more
importantly will get caught on them now
tuck our sauce don't go too crazy the
tartar sauce in here I've got a little
bit of creme fraiche and a little bit of
a little bit a little bit okay a little
bit of mayonnaise
now from there take your gherkins okay
thank you to mrs. thank you right
gherkins in now I'm doing little tartar
sauce okay this is a sort of nice sort
of easy clean with the creme fraiche to
the bone nice no just a touch
just a touch and then from there touches
sauce and this look you're gonna go slow
and then you will be fine so little bit
off it and then from there stop now
think what's happening now the fish is
getting really nice okay and crispy
other tartar sauce that's funny
that's your salat oh really
lemon juice and squeeze some fresh lemon
there okay now look
did you really pass your capers you just
want a really nice amount acidity in
there other half a race and half
CalFresh
that's a few tradition now fries look at
that now
so the fries are blanched okay the good
news is now our turnings around you can
see the exciting part
when with shallow frying okay we shove
it fry it cook so much better and in
many ways a lot healthier
I think IQ of actually cut the actual
chips just a little bit thinner my
eighth grade string source
um okay that's a beautiful sauce I've
got my lemon there and I see the
exciting thing now when we start
literally to shut a fire it's so much
better
deep fry fish raw I blanched them they
are not raw make it Megan really panting
cannon man honey and honey yes yes yes
just a minute 30 seconds
okay
color those now these four beautiful
beautiful from there and tartar sauce is
optional shallow fine is super important
Oscar what do you think down please
[Music]
[Applause]
every time come on really
look how much oil Pat them dry again see
the money no you know what they are
Tiffany cousin oh my god and then and
just start official
I know I'm using the touch but today I'm
gonna put it down to the production crew
okay we're guiding me you'll give me our
time good luck with your fishin trips
make sure you tag me can't wait to see
the pictures if they do know if I'm a
poster bad no I'll still play meantime I
know maybe it's me I know enjoy your
fish and chips god bless have a great
weekend stay safe all around